u.s president donald trump has been
campaigning in the troubled city of
kenosha
wisconsin trump offered support for
police there and accused protesters of
spreading what he called domestic terror
protesters say he's not addressing the
country's
racial divides we'll discuss the visit
here in the studio
after this report
president trump arrived in kenosha on
tuesday
with a firm message of law and order
he condemned last week's protests vowed
to help local businesses damaged during
the demonstrations
as well as defending and praising law
enforcement
to stop the political violence we must
also confront the
radical ideology that includes this
violence
reckless far-left politicians continue
to push
the destructive message that our nation
and our law enforcement are
oppressive or racist they'll throw out
any word
that comes to them the president's visit
prompted more unrest trump supporters
and black lives matter protesters
faced off as he arrived with members of
the black community
condemning his visit
he should just stay away yet because
he's coming down for the wrong reason
he's not coming down here to help he's
coming down here to
force the issue with racism he's not for
us he's not for the country right now
man
since he became president my opinion is
a lot of doors of racism has opened up
kenosha was left partly in ruins
following days of violent protests
after police shot african-american
resident jacob blake in the back in late
august
local leaders had urged trump to stay
away
to prevent inflaming tensions others
disagreed
i feel it's a it's good time for him to
come
anytime because he brings he wants to
bring comfort
and peace to america
and people are hurting right now over
all this
and i feel it's a good time for him to
come i support him
i think the president coming here might
make it safer here
lots of secret service so for the day
so but i think tomorrow when he leaves
it might make it worse
so i have mixed feelings wisconsin
is a crucial battleground state in the
november election
trump won narrowly here in 2016
and he's determined to keep it
republican as he seeks a second term
well can he do that to talk about that
i'm joined by dw's
u.s expert peter hola dahl good morning
to you peter good to see you again
um wisconsin one of the battleground
states of course as we just heard there
for
donald trump he needs to secure a win
there for his election
was this the right move for him to boost
his support
in wisconsin to show up in kenosha
support the police
well i think it's it's a smart move in
as far as he's trying to win over
or went back in fact suburban uh
particularly white voters uh
whom he's lost a lot of ground with over
the past years uh females being uh
especially wife's ass as uh they like to
call them um
and his his message of kind of fear and
carnage
and him being the law and order
president will restore law and order
across america that's uh early polling
suggested that's actually worked quite
well with this particular group
um i think we need to i mean this was
essentially a campaign stop right
he um he
has to benefit as the incumbent
president of wherever he goes become the
national stage that's a benefit that joe
biden does not have and so to be able to
go out there
you know paint this message or in you
know in
big bold letters um that can be very
effective
i think what we also saw though is that
trump to some extent blew a hole in the
image
that his wife the first lady melania
trump his daughters including ivanka
trump and his some of his closest
female advisors try to paint of him you
know during the convention
of someone who is a great empathizer
because
there was a scene yesterday at a round
table where he sat down with to
pastors of jacob blake's mother and they
were asked about
um about systemic of whether police
brutality was
systemic rather than letting them finish
he jumped in and and
pretty much dismissed the question um
when he was asked later directly about
systemic police violence he also tried
to you know cast the blame on
the protesters instead saying that
they're essentially responsible for
police violence he did that in a very um
clear way
in in kenosha he said uh the violent
protesters are
domestic terrorists yeah that's very
strong language of course and
and how does that play this description
of domestic terrorists the protesters of
island protesters specifically being
domestic terrorists how does that play
into his his campaign strategy
well it perfectly aligns with this
message as we just said you know he's
trying to paint these as far-left
radicals
um and i think again it might
work with the suburban housewives for
instance the problem
is that if you start looking comparing
his rhetoric to his own actions
you start seeing a contradiction there
he's repeatedly refused to condemn
violence
uh you know perpetrated by by supporters
of his
for instance kyle rittenhouse who shot
and killed two people
uh during clashes in kenosha who is an
art and trump supporter turns out
and he's now on trial who's now on trial
he's also refused to
distance himself from q anon supporters
a a
conspiracy theory that the fbi has
described as a domestic terrorism
terrorist threat where does this leave
joe biden i mean he's going to have to
come up to the plate and and somehow
address what's happening in american
cities
yeah and he's obviously he's been more
uh sympathetic and taken the sides of
the black lives matter pro says trump
has says
and republicans have tried very hard to
paint joe biden
as someone who's anti-police the numbers
show though that biden would actually
uh you know dedicate 300 million uh to
hire more police he's been very ardent
that he does
that he condemns the violence that we've
seen that that he wants to actually
support
police in their work an important
message from from him right now
the question is to get the democrats on
you'll be able to get it through with
trump because trump has the bigger mic
that is just
the case as president marilla dolls as
ever peter thanks for coming in thank
you
let's take this now to our correspondent
stefan simons he's in kenosha wisconsin
good afternoon to you stefan trump's
visit
very brief there in kenosha did his
visit
did it make a difference on the ground
where you are
it made a difference in terms of that it
brought of course
trump supporters and anti-trump
protesters
are basically close together and they
delivered even if it's now
fairly calm it calmed significantly down
they delivered
each other a shouting match and
chanting black lives matter which were
then responded with
all lives matter which then resulted in
more shouting and yelling of black lives
matter
it seems to be that and that is maybe
also
um something the president doesn't
understand that a few people you do not
understand
unless black lives don't matter it's not
the case that all lives matter so this
has to come first
then all lives matter having said that
um the president characterizing the last
week here in kenosha or today as ravaged
by domestic terrorism that's of course
not the case that is absolutely not the
case yes there were protests here yes
there was violence here
yeah buildings and cars went up in
flames
water bottles were thrown against the
police who answered
that answer then with tear gas and
rubber bullet and pepper spray
then of course there was also the
shooting of a 17 year old teenager
militia type vigilante of two protesters
which the president in the past actually
did only say well neutral or good things
about
nothing towards the black community here
no word of condolences no word of
sympathy
no way that people hear the ones we
talked to
think that this president came here to
unify this town or
this country yeah and stephen the
the white house despite what you just
said there the white house
said that this was a visit to heal and
unite
critics of the president say that it
looked more like a campaign stop by a
president who's running for reelection
what's your take
i would agree with this there is no such
thing as the president
coming anywhere doing anything right now
which now which is not
strictly and straight connected to his
campaign
to his efforts to be re-elected in
november there is no such thing as not
a symbolic policy in place your politics
in place
everything is a photo op everything this
president
as well as mr biden and the democratic
campaign does
is linked to the campaign is linked to
being or having the chance of being
elected
november 3rd is this
right the right thing to do in a time as
america as itself hurts the city hurts
well that's not for me to answer there's
a lot of people who say like
you know we wished all this politics
could go away and we actually could
focus on the
on the problem and that is that america
has to find a way
to solve systemic and structural racism
um but well i think we got to wait for
this a little bit longer
we got about one minute jeff let me ask
you we've heard the u.s president
compare police
shootings to golfers choking on the golf
course missing a golf putt
he seemed to suggest the teenager who
killed two people with that assault
rifle
was acting in self defense is the
president succeeding in
flipping the script on the racial unrest
in kenosha
i don't think so and i actually have no
words for what he said then this
imbalance which is
inherently with what he says is i i who
is
going to rationally and logically
justify this or actually can follow this
all i can't
and that's just my personal opinion but
i know that
from the people i talk to here they're
pretty much along this line this makes
perfect sense for donald trump because
he is
trying to create fear and distrust
division that's what they say and uh
i have to say how he says things
what he said in the last few days
regarding kenosha
it's felt here as exactly that division
dw stefan simon's on the story for us in
kenosha wisconsin
stefan thank you
no matter what the white house press
secretary or surrogates of the president
tell us
president trump's message has not
changed that much over the past four
years from charlottesville to kenosha
the president has been reluctant to
condemn police brutality
against black men he's also been
reluctant to condemn violence and
provocation from the far
right most recently in portland oregon
where a pro-trump caravan descended
over the weekend adding fuel to the
already volatile
city the fatal shooting of a trump
supporter only amplified his calls for
more law and order
my next guest tonight studies this kind
of messaging especially in right-wing
media i'm happy to welcome court knife
to the day
court teaches political science at the
jfk institute at the free university
here in berlin
court it's good to have you on the show
let me start by asking you what did you
think of trump's
visit to kenosha wisconsin today
well i think um great to be here first
of all but um i think your correspondent
did a fantastic job of summarizing this
and as a political scientist it's not
really up to me to say um
you know to call this good or bad but i
mean we we are faced with the question
of what is happening and why and it's
really difficult to find an answer that
doesn't end with because trump is trying
to do something that ultimately benefits
his campaign
you know trump's language has been
supportive
of vigilantes supportive of armed
militias
the president has likened police
shooting a black man in the back seven
times to a golfer choking on the golf
course as we said
who who are these messages meant for
well um i think it's really difficult
for um for
some of you viewers probably um
sometimes even myself to really um
comprehend what the president is talking
about every once in a while and i think
in order to really understand what's
going on and kind of his messaging it's
it's important to consider
who his base is but also the type of
media that he's catering to
so if your viewers were to follow a
different channel
say a fox news but also certainly social
media sites
and a vast right-wing kind of media
ecosystem that exists in the u.s
then they would find a very different
version of what is going on
in these cities they would find a
different version of um
crime statistics of threat scenarios
and it's these things that trump is
evoking and he's he's catering to
um he's very much tuned in to these
channels himself
and this is the narrative that kind of
unfolds so it's it's it's not
necessarily enough to just follow what
the president is saying um sometimes we
need to consider what this
entire kind of news ecosystem this
alternative reality
uh is conjuring that that's a very good
point and the the news diet
that americans consume that's important
and
as you pointed out the right wing media
they
they love the message that they hear
from the president
what about the mainstream media or the
non-political apolitical media if you
will
how have they been handling trump's
messages
well i think um mainstream journalism
has done a much better job of late
in covering trump so one of the one of
the greatest mistakes
that was made early on was just to take
you know what the president was saying
at face value and kind of reporting it
right to quote
whatever trump was saying and oftentimes
this fell into the trap of reporting on
claims you know that had no
um basis and factual reality but
by lending you know a new york times
headline to kind of something that the
president was saying
this sort of gave it uh credence and
then that was echoed um
in in other media sources uh and and you
know took on a life of its own and of
late
journalists have become better at
calling things that the president is
saying outwardly racist
uh at you know um fact checking while
speeches are
uh ongoing um and and i i would say
they've done a better job
the question though remains is if the
audience is still tuned in so whether
people that are reading the new york
times or maybe watching this show
um are actually the ones that are going
to end up you know still making up their
minds
in november yeah that's a good point
that you make if we can reach people who
are not in these
echoed chambers when it comes to media
consumption trumpism we know it's not
just an american phenomenon
it has jumped across the atlantic here
in germany i mean last weekend here in
berlin we saw this bizarre mix of
neo-nazis anti-vaxxers conspiracy
pushers even retired citizens all
together
to protest germany's coronavirus
measures such as face mass and social
distancing
now they even tried to storm the
parliament building after they were told
that donald trump
was in berlin watch and listen
in berlin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now that was that was the speech that
was made just moments before people
actually tried to storm the parliament
building here in berlin
on saturday how did donald
trump how did he get to be the great
unifier of the disaffected
i mean he's an icon of conspiracy
theorists worldwide
i mean protesters here in berlin they
were even carrying the american flag
with his
photo on it
i think one one thing that's important
to stress at this point is
that you know these are still in germany
isolated events uh donald trump is very
unpopular within the german population
and we we want to be careful not to kind
of overstate the importance of these
singular events
that being said though i think
investigating this question what drives
this is really
important and again um the media play a
crucial role
um if you look at it's not just waving
the american flag there was also
iconography pointing towards
the conspiracy narrative of qanon um
and other other such um kind of
conspiracy theories
um and all of this kind of makes a mix
for people that are disaffected with the
mainstream media narrative
and they look towards people and icons
that are outside of this that are deemed
deviant by the mainstream
by mainstream journalism and then
singular um
you know heads of state um a couple of
years ago it might have been vladimir
putin as well
um that you know speak truth to kind of
you know the lying press etc
um gain an importance in these circles
and
and are looked uh to uh for guidance um
so
there's a connection here as well with
people that are disaffected with
mainstream media that don't trust
what they see uh in in you know um
established legacy news outlets and
people that are
willing to believe kind of these
alternative narratives um that the
president
has also you know actively uh reinforced
yeah and it's important as you say it's
perception and it's proportion to that
we have to
keep in mind when we're talking about
these stories court connect
joining us tonight with the jfk
institute here in berlin
court we appreciate your time and your
insights thank you happy to be here bye